Virginia's embattled lieutenant
governor's urgent prosecutors in two
states to investigate sexual assault
allegations against him
Justin Fairfax spoke publicly yesterday
for the very first time since Vanessa
Tyson and Merritt Watson detailed their
accusations he said the woman's
allegations are not true
his comments came as Virginia lawmakers
failed to agree on a proposal to have
the women testify under oath Jeff Pegues
is outside the Capitol in Richmond
Virginia with more on this story Jeff
good morning good morning the two women
at the center of this controversy say
they want to testify in public but
chances are that hearing never happens
it would be unprecedented it would be
politically explosive Fairfax who was a
Democrat says it would not be the right
vehicle to get at the truth I knew that
the allegations made against me were
false from the moment I first heard them
that is why I denied them seeking to
clear his name
Virginia's lieutenant governor Justin
Fairfax released the results of two
polygraph exams each with questions
about his encounters with Vanessa Tyson
and Meredith Watson Fairfax says he
voluntarily took and passed both tests
such conduct is against everything I
have stood for in both my public and
private life Watson and Tyson went
public with their allegations against
the governor in February they spoke with
Gayle King in interviews that aired this
week
and it's holding my head so I can't lift
like i'm trying to lift my head back in
initially there was a couch and he
pulled me over and i tried several times
to get up and was pushed back to him
held down fairfax disputes many of the
details the women put forward including
when Tyson says they first met on July
26th at the 2004 Democratic convention
senator Edwards and I were not in Boston
on that date Fairfax maintains both
encounters were consensual I did not
rape or sexually assault meredith watson
state Republicans have called for a
bipartisan public hearing later this
year that would Pitt Fairfax against his
two accusers Todd Gilbert is the
majority leader and wouldn't that just
be a political stunt this is is
too important and too compelling to be
left to see being framed as some sort of
partisan effort Fairfax's said he
believes that a public hearing would
only sensationalize the allegations
against him but his accusers say it
offers complete transparency Nora all
right Jeff thank you that is exactly
what they say someone asked me the other
day they asked me will Gail have you
seen the Muller report no I think that
that's why they want a hearing as
opposed to an investigation that's
something to think about